[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
give them another shot of morphine and
take him to the surgical Town yes put on
another dressing just you'll be all
right
he finally got a box over his back I
guess they had to pull him up he can't
walk you can't find a scratch on him
take a hold of yourself Soldier what's
your name
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
all right get him out of here
shell shocked
evacuate
[Music]
and now we have this patient here in our
hospital two months after the breakdown
occurred
the variety of neurosis which he
exhibits is not an unusual one on the
battlefield
many errors have been made in his case
for one thing his EMT tag is labeled
shell shock
the Army choice of term is exhaustion
and this term will be used exclusively
for all forms of neurosis in echelon's
forward of the evacuation Hospital
the reason is obvious
soldiers read their tags
and long-involved medical terms serve
only to confuse an already Disturbed
mind
now
placing yourself in the situation of
this medical officer at the clearing
station what would you have done for
John Clemens
I don't see what else the officer could
have done there seems no point in
keeping a patient like this on the
battlefield any other comments major
we're going to be busy out there with
patients who are really shot up and we
won't have time to Monkey around with
guys like that
major I'm a sergeant it looks to me like
this is a job for psychiatrists
that Soldier must have been a misfit
from the start to break down like that
the medical record shows that the
soldier was a healthy normal individual
before he underwent the experience that
caused his illness
high school graduate played an end on
the football team
had a creditable job in a Pittsburgh
steel mill after he left school at the
age of 18.
in brief he displays the picture of a
typical American Boy
and now he's sick and unless we do
something for him he may remain sick for
an indefinite period of time
gentlemen
you are not requested to treat these
patients you're directed to do so
may I acquaint you with a few statistics
from recent campaigns the size of the
problem will startle you
these figures from Italy seem to
indicate that 20 percent of all the
non-fatal battle casualties were not
wounded they were suffering from
neurosis
incisionly the overall figure for the
entire campaign was
14.9 percent
when you add up the easy and the hard
days of the Tunisian campaign
you will find that 16 percent
of all the non-fatal casualties were
suffering from neurosis
in prolonged engagements
where the going is really tough
we find that 30 to 50 percent
of all men coming under your care in the
divisional area
are suffering from combat exhaustion
gentlemen that means that one out of
three or even one out of two of all
soldiers coming under medical canvas
does not have a drop of blood on him
now
don't get the idea that the American GI
is the only soldier that develops
neurosis
parallel statistics of the armies of our
allies and enemies show that they are
faced with the same problem
you are members of the medical
Department
and to use entrusted the care of all the
sick
there are no Specialists on the
battlefield
if you say that you are a surgeon
and can handle only the surgically
wounded you have failed in your mission
out in the mud you've got to be a
medical Soldier and meet all comers
in the folder issued to you you will
find a copy of this chart depicting the
various forms of neurosis
hysteria anxiety state reactive
depression and a terror State this will
act as a guide to us as we visit the
wards where we can observe actual cases
[Applause]
you may be seated
good morning McKenna how are you feeling
now I don't know sir
I'm afraid you'll have to give me up as
a bad job
I'll never get well oh it isn't as bad
as all that is it
I can't stop from crying like a damn
poor baby the blues I guess
you did pretty well before the war
didn't you I did all right I suppose
this man has an excellent background he
averaged 400 a month as an automobile
salesman in Chicago
why did they send you here McKenna we
get stuck out in Katherine pass
they had to send up reinforcements
the new CEO had no use for me thought I
was a sad Psych
I don't blame them oh you'll feel better
in a week or so take my word for it
McKenna went through most of the North
African campaign the death of his Co
plus the loss of many of his friends
plus prolonged physical fatigue have
produced a reactive depression wow and
lots of other fellows have been through
the same thing maybe you pick and shovel
and a little discipline would fix him up
what does usually happen to these cases
major unless properly treated
suicide may occur
these gentlemen are medical officers
sergeant and they're interested in your
story would you mind telling us what's
the matter with you well sir I just
can't seem to get my strength back
I fill all in
they get me up for childhood I can
hardly make it to the line how long has
this been going on
well I know it's the first on the boat
coming to England when did you arrive
from the states well I don't think you
understand Lieutenant this man has just
derived from Sicily did you see much
action kasharski well sir we took a
terrible shylocking at Randazzo
I lost a lot of my buddies there
did you stand up pretty well during that
campaign well sir except having the
Jitters once I stood up as well as
anybody else in what way do you feel
your weakness well sir it's all over
mostly in my chest the pains I get out
of breath maybe I got TB oh I'll bet 101
against that
this is also a depression with Accent on
the physical rather than the emotional
side is in the first case
would you mind showing us your foot it's
all healed up isn't it yes sir
they mixed it up in the surgical Ward
tell us how it happened
I was cleaning my gun in the bivouac
area
and it went off
accidentally that was outside of troina
wasn't it yes didn't you try to save one
of your men
oh that
that was after we'd landed at Sicily
our company had to retreat
one of our men couldn't keep up with us
he was wounded we lost sight of him
another fellow and myself asked the CEO
if we couldn't go back and get him
we got him all right
as we started back
Jerry spotted us and laid down a barrage
of mortar fire that was like all hell
breaking loose
we had to leave him behind
what happened to him
he died out there
how soon after that did you have your
accident about a week or so what shape
are you in jittery
couldn't sleep much
kept thinking about that day
thank you Corporal is that a common
occurrence in depression major
in the Battle of Boyz and litson there
were 3 000 cases like that the commander
asked his chief surgeon to investigate
he found that they were self-inflicted
Floyd that's a German name who was the
commander Napoleon
at ease Peters you're in the air car
aren't you would you mind telling us
about yourself
no sir don't mind a bit I just refused
to fly were you scared
no I don't think so sir
see my waste gun on a bomber
a bomber's cruise just like a football
team
one fellow keeps fumbling the ball all
the time a lot of good guys on the
losing team tell us what happened that
day you refused to fly hey briefed us to
go over Berlin that morning
and I was feeling terribly nervous and
shaky
I hadn't slept for about three nights
and as we were walking over towards the
ship I thought that butterflies in my
stomach worse than ever
so I just told them it didn't make any
difference to me whether they busted me
or not
the guy in that shape just shouldn't go
up do you always get butterflies when
you go up
no I think that started when we were
shot up over the drink
we ditched out there
and the pilot and the Weir Gunner were
both killed
took him about three days before they
finally pissed us out and I don't think
I've ever been the same since
how do you feel about going back to
flying
all right means a hell of a lot to me
the nerves clear up I'll do everything
they want me to
I think I'm washed out now
they'll never let me fly again well
let's cross that bridge when we come to
it sit down Peters
you may call him a gold brick if you
want to but take a look at this
he's had 20 missions
and he's been decorated four times
this is another form of exhaustion known
to the air core as operational fatigue
we now come to an extremely common
variety of the anxiety state
at first glance this patient might
appear to have Parkinson's disease but
in reality he is suffering from
exhaustion note the rhythmic Tremor of
his lips
of his hands
of his knees
of his feet
he was pinned down by enemy mortar fire
and cut off in an observation post for
the better part of four days
he was flown into us this morning from
the combat area
speech is difficult so we won't burden
him with questions
treatment will begin immediately yes sir
here we have a variety of anxiety
Neurosis with visceral dysfunction how
is your stomach I vomited again sir
Eddie's Soldier how long has this been
going on it started when I was in action
about six weeks ago have you lost any
weight about 30 pounds so they tell me
we'll soon make that up for you here any
other complaints well everything seems
Torn to Pieces my heart beats awfully
fast my stomach I just can't seem to get
over my diarrhea how do you sleep
it'll be all right if it weren't for
those dreams do you dream about anything
in particular terrible stuff
The Barrage strafing being stuck out in
a foxhole
memories uh sort of doesn't always
bother you I want to jump out of bed
every time a plane goes overhead I've
been so nervous and jittery I can't even
write look at here
[Music]
well don't worry too much Soldier you'll
be better soon
and now we come to a case of back pain
with no organic bases
where is the pain it's right here
between my shoulder blades sir
how long has it been going on
well it's been worse for the past couple
weeks
since I was trying to live in a GI can
but I've had this trouble ever since I
was about eight years old and I fell off
a wagon and hurt my back
my heart is bad it gives me a lot of
trouble
and my nerves are bad too
how do you feel about going back to duty
I don't know my back doesn't get any
better
and my heart still gives me trouble and
you can see my nerves no better
all right Soldier that's all thank you
no organic basis has been found for his
complaint
gentlemen this is a type of
constitutional inadequacy in which there
is a fixed somatic complaint in addition
to diffuse anxiety symptoms
he has brought his complaint with him
into the army his chances of
Rehabilitation are slight and he should
be weeded out as quickly as possible
because he would be one of the first to
break down in combat
if you will look at your chart
you will find that we have dealt with
the various forms of reactive depression
and the anxiety state
there are other types of combat
exhaustion
the terror state of panic and stupor and
the hysterical state of Amnesia our
seldom met with in hospitals this far
from the front
however we do have an interesting
patient in the ward
who went through an episode of
hysterical Amnesia with wandering or
Feud as it is called
sit down Kelly
would you mind telling these medical
officers something about that lapse of
memory you've had Oh you mean the time I
went over the hill Down in Africa and
didn't know anything about it yes
weren't you wounded down there oh that
was long before that immature the Jerry
Sniper got me in the arm that's right
they patched you up in a hospital and
sent you to an outfit near Metro what
shape were you in did you feel fit hell
no I was jittering couldn't get my
strength back but African campaign was
over so we just hung around doing
problems and stuff like that
and now tell us what happened on that
problem when they were using live
ammunition
well we were out on a problem and moving
to take a hill it was shooting 105 and
some of them fell short they were
busting right over us enough to give
anyone the Jitters then one busted right
over my head I ducked next thing I
remember I found myself in the side
street and Al Jared several days later I
looked at myself and looked like I'd
been on a three-week drunk
I was pretty dirty so ducked into a
barber shop got a shave the brush up
then I called on the MPS and what did
the MPS do well nobody believe a story
so they tossed me in the claim well I
was there and the medical officer saw
how junky I was so they shipped me here
although nobody would believe his story
you may bet on it as a true one because
it is so typical of what is encountered
on the battlefield
rather strange don't you think he went
through a half a dozen battles and then
broke down on a maneuver
and now we come to the case that was
under discussion in the classroom John
Clemens may I have his record
he represents another of the hysterias
conversion type
since no definitive treatment has been
given him you will find that his
clinical condition has not changed
between the time he left combat and his
arrival here a few days ago
and now Clemens
we want to see you walk
yes sir only I'll have to have some help
sir will you help him search
I'll walk down that way
I think you can walk by yourself Clemens
trial
go ahead
that's it
now back
that's it come along
all right
now Bend forward as far as you can
is that as much as you can bend yes sir
now been back
is that as far as you can bend I'm
afraid Souls there
careful diagnostic Studies have been
made on this patient
no Orthopedic or neurologic disease is
present
x-rays are negative
this is a conversion phenomenon
known as campto carmium
which is Greek for bent back
what do you bring in the chair sergeant
and now Clemens will you tell these
gentlemen all you can remember the way
this started
there's not much I can remember sir
out of a mountain Lane wire one night
when Jerry opened up with everything he
had
so I dove for the nearest Fox Bowl
and then
I don't know it's all hazy
I was scared
I'm sorry sir
I just can't think of much more
and suddenly I felt people pulling me
out I was all twisted up oh yes you told
us about the Medics pulling you out
and that's all of his story that he
remembers
and now gentlemen we come to the subject
of treatment
the other patients you have just seen
will be treated by prolonged deep sleep
or Narcosis therapy
but we are going to treat this patient
with chemical hypnosis
this should restore his normal posture
chemical hypnosis produces a state of
semi-sleep or Twilight state in which
suggestibility is increased as it is in
true hypnotism
by using this suggestibility and by
inducing AB reaction a cure of his
condition can be brought about
if you will follow me the treatment of
this patient will be demonstrated
major will you take over please yes
while we are waiting for the patient let
us review some of the drugs used in
Narcosis therapy and chemical hypnosis
the drugs of choice are the barbiturates
the most practical one for producing and
maintaining Narcosis is this one
sodium amital
there is an ample supply of it in your
number two chest
on the average 9 to 12 grains will
produce adequate Narcosis for from seven
to eight hours
when he wakes up the patient can be fed
and taken to the latrine
this no Savannah May then be repeated
and the Narcosis thus continued as long
as necessary
patients with fully developed varieties
of combat exhaustion will require a
minimum of 24 hours of continuous
narcosis
some will require 48 to 72 hours
a second barbiturate with an action
almost identical with that of sodium
ammetal is an embutal
four and a half to six grains every
seven or eight hours
you will note that in combat exhaustion
massive doses of these drugs are needed
in therapy
a third barbiturate is the familiar drug
phenobarbital
tablets are one-half grain
four and a half grains will usually
produce adequate Narcosis but on
occasion six grains may be necessary
you can expect sleep for longer periods
than with sodium ammetal or nembutel
its action may be estimated at 10 to 12
hours after which you may proceed is
with the first two drugs
another drug available to you is sodium
bromide
its use is suggested only when others
cannot be obtained
dosage is extremely variable
its action is inconstant and it tends to
pile up in the bloodstream so that toxic
States May develop
in an emergency
inhalation anesthetic such as ether may
be used to put a struggling panicky
patient to sleep quickly
drugs may also be used intravenously
a 10 solution of sodium ammetal may be
administered with Orthodox technique
the rate of administration is one cubic
centimeter a minute
the average patient will go to sleep
after the administration of five to
eight ccs and will remain asleep for
seven to eight hours
in our case however we will use another
intravenous drug pentathal
Lieutenant will you prepare this
pedophile is not a good drug for
Narcosis therapy
it will put your patient to sleep
quickly and effectively but its action
is extremely short
for our purposes the chief value of
pedophile is in producing chemical
hypnosis a form of semi-narcosis or
Twilight state
we will use a two percent solution of
pedophile
pre-medication with atropine has been
given
our patient is ready now
Clemens this medicine will relax your
muscles completely
and help your back
the rate of administration is two CC's
per minute
a major when you keep time please
you'll feel the brink of the needle now
ready off
do you feel any effect
no sir only my head swimming a bit
one minute
we continue the administration at the
rate of two CC's per minute
how do you feel now Clemens
you're getting kind of drunk like a
cheap Jay
don't you mind
one of the early effects of pedestal
Administration is this feeling of
well-being
two minutes
now say Methodist Episcopal for me
Clements
Methodist Episcopal
you will notice the slurring of speech
he is beginning to have difficulty with
enunciation this shows that the drug is
having effect
three minutes
we have now injected six cc's of the
solution
how are you feeling
come again and feel awful jokes sir
don't let that bother you
that just shows it's taking effect
doesn't it yes sure
this is great stuff for your back it'll
help you straighten out
four minutes
we have now almost reached the level of
chemical hypnosis what the hell does
that mean that means we're really going
to fix you up
there is a very simple test for the
determination of the optimum level of
chemical hypnosis
we'll have the patient count backward
from a hundred and when he becomes
confused we'll know he is at the right
stage
and tomorrow he won't remember having
counted it all
at this level he will be extremely
suggestible
um
can we get an office lady
I think I'm going to pass out hey don't
you go to sleep on me I want you to
count backwards count backwards from a
hundred
99
.
7
now we can remove the needle
let's straighten him out his bed put him
on his back
[Music]
he hit me
[Music]
downward
I've gotta get out of here
I can't move
come down here
we're leaving
to die
call
what the hell are those
[Applause]
push myself
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
insurance
I don't want to turn around and see what
he's doing
oh my God
oh my God
the guy you're breaking my back
take it easy Soldier take it easy
your muscles are relaxed now fly quietly
and rest your back is all straight
this gentleman was the phenomenon of
every action sometimes it is necessary
to coach the patient to relive the
emotional stresses of the events which
produced his hysteria but it is more
common for it to happen spontaneously as
it did here
now he has it off his chest and this is
the time for suggestive therapy
remember that pedestal increases the
suggestibility
your back is straight and strong
your back is fine and straight
really of course let's sit up
but I can't sir we'll help you
of course you can there you are but it
hurts that's only those muscles you
haven't used for a long time let's Bend
forward
way down
go back
there you are it is better of course now
backwards
why are you doing as well as any of us
wouldn't you like to see how well you
can walk but I'll fall sir oh no we'll
help you
your back's all right now
walk by yourself Soldier
where am I what's happening we
straightened your back for you see
you're walking straight turn around
throw back your shoulders
oh let's see walk like a soldier
come back
geez
treatment is not complete in this case
Clemens will now go through a general
reconditioning program which will give
him confidence and which will complete
what we started here this morning
okay
what kind of treatment will he get major
that question can best be answered by
giving you a summary of the operational
plan of this hospital it is divided into
three sections admission treatment and
Rehabilitation
shortly after his arrival each patient
is given a complete physical examination
in order to ascertain the cause of his
illness this includes Dental survey and
any necessary laboratory studies
these are followed by intelligence tests
and complete mental examinations
if necessary specialized psychiatric
studies such as the Rorschach technique
or other personality tests are made
after careful summary of these findings
treatment is based upon the physical and
psychological background of the patient
and the symptoms he presents
Narcosis therapy or continuous sleep
treatment have proved of Great Value in
a large series of cases many patients
showing marked anxiety tension inability
to sleep chronic fatigue or emotional
instability respond to this treatment
by giving them sodium ametol or other
barbiturates the patients are kept to
sleep 18 to 20 hours per day for several
days
in other Wars Narcosis and modified
insulin therapies are combined insulin
is given in the morning and Narcosis is
carried out in the afternoon and evening
as where Mitchell found in the American
Civil War soldiers with combat
exhaustion almost invariably suffered
great loss of weight the insulin
treatment consists of the administration
up from 40 to 100 units each morning
before breakfast
with this chemical stimulation of
appetite the patient eats on an average
12 and a half pounds of food per day
which is more than twice the amount
normally consumed
[Music]
by means of this combination of
therapies symptoms of acute tension are
relieved and the restoration of weight
can be expected at the rate of a half to
one pound per day
[Music]
attention to diet
is an important part of the therapeutic
program
balanced meals are planned for high
caloric value and proper vitamin content
patients who show marked symptoms of
reactive depression may be given
electrical shock treatment in addition
to the combination insulin and Narcosis
therapy
[Music]
as previously demonstrated
narco-analysis and hypnosis are used to
eliminate amnesic symptoms
suggestion either direct or in the form
of hypnosis or Narco suggestion is
employed in conversion Hysteria
during the therapeutic period patients
go through a program of exercises
designed to maintain physical fitness
individual or group re-education is
undertaken so that patients May
understand the cause of their illness
after patients have completed their
treatment they are placed in a training
company
here they live in a barracks and are
given a review of military training
foreign
[Music]
hikes
detail work
sensible occupational therapy projects
leading to constructive ends and of a
type consistent with the job of a field
Soldier
yeah
sports are included for physical
hardening coordination of muscle and the
fostering of team spirit
[Music]
during the training company period a
series of discussions is undertaken to
review for the soldier the reasons why
we fight
all serve to rehabilitate the soldier
observe him under military conditions
prepare him once more for Army life
and ultimately return him to active duty
are there any questions what percentage
of cases are you returning to active
duty from this Hospital major we're all
impressed with what we've seen you've
got a swell set up here everything you
need yes but what about us in the combat
area with our hands full and not a thing
to work with
I was coming to all that gentleman early
treatment in the combat zone does not
require elaborate facilities and would
eliminate most of our setup here
we in the communication Zone despite all
the facilities can return only a very
small percentage of patients to actual
combat Duty whereas you out in the
forward area can by getting at them
early send 70 to 80 percent back to duty
in the front line
you have been shown around this Hospital
in order to acquaint you with the
principles underlying the treatment of
combat exhaustion
treatment in the forward area is based
on identical principles modified to meet
the Tactical demand
when patients arrive at the clearing
station it is a primary importance
physically injured
crazy
take him to ten five right away we'll
get the rest of the information after
he's had treatments
[Applause]
[Music]
take off his helmet don't you take my
helmet off damn it I gotta get out of
here you're all crazy they're gonna sell
it even the other doc said so hey you
guys get out of here go get this place
[Music]
take it easy take it easy
take it easy Soldier
[Music]
let me go you saw the Red Cross outside
that means you're in a hospital yeah let
me go
take it easy
just relax take it easy that's right
take it easy you're in a tank nothing
will hurt you now we'll take care of you
travel holding he'll be quiet now better
put him in a pact though in case he's
excited when he wakes take him and put
him in the end space over there
[Music]
sit him down on this litter
bring him some soup
Campbell put seven and a half grain
sodium amethyle in a series
sit on this chest Soldier
take off your path
what's your trouble Soldier
I'm all tired of my headaches my ankle
over are you wounded anywhere no sir
it's just it I never was a Goldberg no I
don't even want to clean off my gun
can't understand it
oh you're from that outfit that had hell
shot out a little while back
yes
that's your trouble you're just worn out
what you need is some rest and some food
bring me 12 grains of amitol Campbell
that's right take them all
that's fine you feel better now
bring him some soup and some blankets
pick up your pack Soldier
put him in the third space drink that
soup Soldier get some sleep and you'll
be all right
now we can take care of you
just lie back something
roll up his Sue Campbell
swab off his arm
but I want you to realize is that you're
exhausted
The Strain has worn you down
this strain causes muscle tension that's
this muscle tension that makes you shake
like that
don't worry about that
I'm going to inject some medicine that
will work through your entire body relax
your muscles
when the muscles are relaxed the shakes
will be gone
don't move now you can feel a little
sick
you can breathe easier now
take a deep breath try it
that's it
look at your hand
it's not shaking anymore that's because
the muscles are relaxed
I'll give you the rest of the medicine
and you will go sound asleep
when you wake the shakes will be gone
you will feel well
you hear me the shakes will be gone you
feel well you feel perfectly well
he's asleep now you can cover him up
just a minute Pat how are you feeling
the pain in my chest seems gone sir I
feel a little dizzy though that pain is
gone the dizziness will wear off in an
hour or two
how are the shapes let's see your hands
put on your helmet let's go outside
now Pat
I'd like to find something for you to do
until we get Transportation back to your
outfit okay I'll do what I can good come
with me
Sergeant when are you pulling out this
afternoon sir need some help with the
loading yes good here's your man report
back to me when you're finished I'll
find something else for you to do yes
that'll be all
you know
good afternoon sir
don't get out how are you feeling fine
sir haven't had any more trouble with my
hand as good as new but I keep on
wondering why it went bad on me I wasn't
hurt well here's one way it could have
happened
when the bomb struck your hand was
buried in the dirt you couldn't move it
you made the mistake and thought it was
injured
I believe you're right sir that sounds
kind of fishy doesn't it not at all when
you're scared we all get scared on the
battlefield you imagine a lot of things
then two when your mind is tired you're
liable to make mistakes that's what
happened to you you've had treatment in
your hand as well you're ready to return
to duty now sure glad of that's there
good there's an outfit going up in just
a few minutes near where your old outfit
is think you can make it I'll be with
you in a moment sir get your stuff so
long major just a second Lieutenant
you're going forward I've got a
passenger for you we'll have to hurry
the old man wants me report immediately
to the disposition 10. I'll clear your
papers in a few minutes after that
report to Sergeant Knight yes sir
he's an exhaustion case isn't he yes
that's why I want you to pay special
attention to him see that he gets an
even break too often line officers
confuse cowardice with fear that's true
keep an eye on him see that he gets his
old assignment without preferential
treatment good luck thanks
sir Lieutenant Burke oh fired Lieutenant
yes sir ready to leave now
that is now that's an important job out
there especially right now I guess you
know the Tactical situation yes sir I've
just been to S3 good
the thing I want to go over with you is
the fact that those troops up there have
been driving hard for a long time now
and are beginning to show evidence of
combat exhaustion
I want you to catch them before this
develops
the prodromal stage is a time to treat
these men watch for the early signs the
most prominent of these are poor
physical coordination slowing of mental
processes
excessive reaction to noise inability to
relax or rest even when there is
opportunity
and outbursts of temper over trivial
matters
getting them sleep lately you can't
sleep around here you have the
facilities of sedation and reassurance
use them
see that he gets a wash
a hot meal
a good night's rest
treatment prevents casualties from
combat exhaustion
prevents long evacuation and preserves
fighting strength
[Music]